okay guess what this shows about to buy
- yeah I bought to you it's brought
about - by the cashier ID number one
finance app in the App Store yep you
know the cash app and you know that it's
the easiest way to send money of your
friends but cash out this way more than
that exclamation mark cash app also
comes with what cash card which I hadn't
used today on what coffee you save
alright the one that you left your
credit card at then yes that was so
traumatic your face okay first of all I
think me leave my wallet is equal to you
being panned about Christmas lights
let's just say that's fair it's a free
debit card and it comes with boosts
which are like instant rewards for
shopping at the places you already learn
you can get up to 10% off your entire
purchase at door - you can even save
every time you shop at Whole Foods
tarjay are we allowed to do that and
more if your gross way to try and grow
your money with their new investing
feature I love this unlike investing
tools that force you to buy entire
shares of stock lame cash app lets you
invest in as little or as much as you
want this way you can still own a piece
of any stock with just one dollar
what's all I have services are provided
by cash I've been vesting a subsidiary
of square member of yes IP C I'm also
excited to be working with cash up to
support one of my favorite organizations
what is it
the driver front yeah yes read the rest
let's see what you got um George time to
be working through every project when
you sign up for the cash app and use the
promo code Whitney not only do you
instantly receive ten dollars but cash
app will also donate ten dollars to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
that provides crisis intervention
suicide prevention services to LGBTQ
youth across America
[Music]
where are you gonna pray where do we
even start
we've known each other for a while we
have I really have did I know I don't
think I knew I knew John before I knew
you
yes Oh John when he wasn't with you I
think I did it's been so long I'm so old
now you are it I was gonna say something
you have not look at aged you are aging
back it's your Benjamin I'm Benjamin
Button I never gonna be old man baby
Brad Pitt soon because I want to be it
does everyone ask you who's gonna play
you in the movie of this yeah who is it
I should pick someone really funny I
should have a good answer to that can
you write me a joke Andrus Michael Pitt
is they've Shiloh Jolie so it really is
a great choice by the way this is very
flattering and it should be flight 14
lean into the joke that everyone thinks
you're stuck it's a long time to make
movies thank you I've cast the whole
movie by the way great yeah and honestly
you should just produce that shit I
think I'm going to I will of course play
Lisa bloom I know I know I love a little
Whitney acting it should happen more ahh
and I I could see Lisa bloom which this
is so important and this is I'm just
gonna jump in you know I've spent the
last two years for the most part
fighting with my guy friends about this
sexual harassment assault reckoning
global reckoning okay and I spend most
of the time you know debunking a lot of
their fears you know you know they're
being dismissive about about people and
I think something that's so important
about this book catch and kill which by
the way I have almost every page
earmarked look it's very moving to me
Whitney look at this look at all my
notes
this is cry mean these are the
scribblings of a mad lady but I mean I
have notes on every page I really read
it circled things I really this is the
first book I finished in years maybe
like 12 years this makes my day you know
it's there are so many real-life people
and such high real-life mistakes that I
was very careful to put the report
first obviously it had to be bulletproof
from a fact-checking standpoint out but
there was a lot of craft involved in
also trying to put that information into
a shape that was accessible and people
would connect with right oh it is it I
did not pee when I was reading this book
a friend was like you need to get up a
piano I can't this is we're just a Lisa
bloom just call back you know and but I
I'm bringing up Lisa bloom first because
I think you know a lot of people think
that this moment is a binary moment men
versus women it's not in this book you
know some men are the biggest heroes and
some women are the biggest villains you
know this isn't all men are bad so oh
yeah I get the question all the time
well what do you think these women who
helped aid and abet predators and I
honestly I never framed it in that way
in my mind because first of all there's
a really solid gender mix of evil people
right and and you know the Lisa blooms
gender is so far down on the list of
significant traits that made her so
ethically it's just not even nothing
that I would have thought of and you
know the hypocrisy runs rife with guys
who claim to be principled too so right
but it's just you know rich McHugh who
will talk about who's one of your
producers at NBC Remnick who was the
editor of senior our heroes so guys calm
down we love men no one's attacking more
guys these great guys in here most men
are great and lots and lots of brave
women yes correct which we will get to
casting rich McHugh because I want
everyone to have like a visual as we go
through this Sean Astin had a good one I
was gonna pitch Mark Ruffalo and Steve
or Steve Coogan no it's good not as good
no Kuni that's that's a that's real
curve ball it is expected that I don't
know he looks like so that's just a me
based on just like reading about him and
then Andy lack who is a monster
I'm allowed to say it you probably are I
can I'm an e like it's another person
NBC who tried to squash these stories
despite the incredible amount of
riveting shocking evidence that you had
is he Jeff Goldblum
or val kilmer or Mitch McConnell Merrill
right yeah I mean if she doesn't want
pervy which are maybe too close to home
no for Harvey we should cast the blob
from Big Trouble in Little China I'm
sure it's still in a warehouse somewhere
I can't laugh at that I know you can't
have to not demonize I know he's a
complicated figure who did a lot of
crimes and we're gonna do I'm we're
gonna talk about Harvey quite a lot but
I want to say something that to me one
of the most important sentences in the
book to me you'll never guess what it is
and there's no point of me quizzing you
okay besides your proposal to my very
good friend John Levin
which I love that he said sure that is
so John well he also I think I excluded
from the final edit the the full
sequence was I had this cute idea of
putting it in the draft and then asking
him for notes on the draft uh and then
he John Lovett notes as you all know pod
save America infamy I would even want
his notes I'm sure he would hurt my
feelings
oh he's brutal brutal and and like it's
not just a content thing it's actually
that he doesn't know how to deliver the
notes without getting very strident
about it yes and he's so direct and he's
so obsessed with justice and he so
doesn't have time for you know trivial
things like write motions totally or
feeling a bedside manner yeah but
they're great notes always always great
notes always so I asked him for notes
he's a very busy guy
it's podcast mogul mm-hmm second only to
you mogul oh no I don't have an umbrella
I don't have an umbrella of pods right
yeah he has a pod mypods the pods despot
he really is and so it's really can
antitrust law hear me stop crooked media
so it took him months and then he was
very generous and did read it but he
skimmed it so fast that he came back at
me and he's like you know if this note
and that note in the other note and I'm
like what did you think of it you put
yourself out there and he's like why
what what's at the end I'm like the
question he said wait deep do you
propose to me in this book like spoilers
not answering that question you need to
read a draft and then he texted back
sure or he put it in the draft he said
it he said it he said it okay sure
anyway right totally
actually then there was this awkward
process of like the the editors and
fact-checkers and lawyers all knew about
the proposal before he did yeah and it
had to be in the draft with like a
fact-checking TK like like a Wikipedia
style pending confirmation right
parenthetical right and I'm like he's
gonna respond at some point we'll just
cut the graph if he says no I'm not
gonna keep in and then he said not so
much but on the way can I get more
volume in my headphones been claiming
his space he's claiming a space he's
leaning in I love it but I think you
have bad headphone I mean not the
hardware but the setup is not trust me
after the last time we went through this
I mean I don't even know if they're
plugged in I don't know what's happening
ladies had fun yeah and I think I'm
being sabotage I think I'm I feel like I
was cut the audio that's part of the
part of the production of Jackie to
which I need people to understand when
you're reading this book there's so many
riveting things about it and there's so
many things that you're just like so
hard to believe and you put the facts
out in such a way that they can just
speak for themselves and I think that's
Noah Oppenheim this guy who's a producer
at NBC who kept squatched the president
of NB the president of NBC is he who's
he gonna pull it who's gonna be played
play him Rowan Atkinson a actual ball of
slime
well John actually suggested another
curve ball Matthew McConaughey oh he has
a little bit of a first of all you have
to love him at first right okay good the
plots were okay as I did you have to we
have to be kind of you have to see that
I look up to him and I think he's cool
that makes sense
and and he has you know I think I
described him as being a doe-eyed stoner
so the lack of backbone and complicity
was was shocking so it can't be this is
someone who betrays that immediately I
just can't picture Matthew McConaughey
writing a script Matthew McConaughey
wrote it which by the way it's already a
red flag that the president nBC wrote a
movie about a woman who's crying for two
hours like why is that the story you're
choosing to tell dude why is that
something you're so passionate about
telling I didn't realize until I went
through all the transcripts that by the
way this is better whatever you did
thank you did or nothing happened oh you
did thank noms I don't know whether this
is a placebo and I being ghastly like I
didn't realize until I got into the
reporting and the reviewing all the
transcripts and records and stuff how
many people hated Jackie and I actually
I have I would say mixed feelings about
Jackie she's great in it score is great
that's right
great score yep that's what Mika levy
that's what people say about movies they
don't like great score it's such a good
score well so the costumes were
incredible the first pass the costumes
and the first pass of the of the book
which was I shit you not a thousand pair
can we curse on Punk yes of course
please
actually right you do nothing but if you
want to you can this I mean this is
gonna be the least profane and also by
far the least sexy episode of the
Whitney pahud oh we haven't even really
started yet just wait yeah but people
had these strong feelings about Jackie
that I didn't expect stronger even than
mine and the first version of those the
edits of those scenes had like a double
punch line of the Runner of people
saying like well Jackie and then me
every time saying but the soundtrack was
great I loved the score I just I as a
civilian of the United States it bothers
me that the president of NBC News has a
side hustle of trying to write movies in
Hollywood and covering
a business in a biased way I mean how
are you expected to objectively cover a
business you're trying to get ahead in
well you know I as with every part of
the report and the book is really really
fair to no op and I'm very even-handed
and it gets in any kind of rebuttal that
he has about defending his conduct here
but when I present these parts of who he
is that he had these dreams of success
in Hollywood and was connecting with
Harvey Weinstein in a certain way Harvey
Weinstein certainly at the very least
was communicating with Noah Oppenheim in
a certain way that was expected he was
essentially signing up to cover a
business or to cover Harvey Weinstein a
man whose approval and money he probably
wanted right it's been subsequently
reported that Harvey Weinstein was
interested in acquiring Jackie at one
point I mean it is all very incestuous
and I present that you know with all the
caveats of I wanted to believe and in
fact it never occurred to me that there
would be anything but just a firewall
between those parts of his life right
but I think the judgment that he had
speaks for itself and there wasn't a
firewall and and it's the same thing for
you know those college writings that I
uncovered where he was saying you know
women love to be pumped full of alcohol
and assaulted the man that runs NBC News
currently still works there it's pretty
crazy stuff even for a senior at Harvard
- right
you know just women are asking for a
type argument that in the crimson the
Harvard Crimson Journal and would go to
kind of feminist gatherings and pose as
a supporter and then write these
articles saying you know this is all
bullshit really had a very specific set
of views about the value of women's
voices and the value of women's bodies
and autonomy and consent sounds cool
sounds like a cool guy I want to get to
what you just said about Harvey because
you know oh you there's a sentence in
the book it was really powerful and and
you know veracity comes first with you
you wrote after you got off the phone
with Harvey you gave him plenty of
opportunities to weigh in I you were so
fair to him that it was you know it's
like a roller cut every time you talk to
him is like ah you gave him so many
opportunities to weigh in and he said
that he's funny and I
it's so important that people know that
because you know a lot of these you know
megalomaniac narcissists monsters are
not just one thing you know I think it's
hard for us as a species it's almost our
work or we have our work cut out for us
as a species to be able to believe that
two things can be true at the same time
this is a man who is a complete monster
who's committing these heinous crimes
for 30 years but was also funny and
smart and engaging and sent gifts like
you know the Gray Goose gifts this was a
man I mean there's no way he could have
had this ascendancy without being
charming I mean you read that email he
sends Noah Oppenheim after no op and I'm
kills the story saying you know Megan
Kelly's new program is terrific it's so
smart a bottle of great yes yes yes you
know in the calls people Geils people in
a very and a lot of you know start
dangling we should work together kind of
stuff and that was his move that's the
way he operated and I'm now doing this
podcast which is kind of a side quill to
the book it's deep dive little
true-crime documentaries about
characters in the book yeah including
some characters who wouldn't speak for
the reporting so we did this episode on
a former Weinstein assistant who shows
up briefly in the narrative as someone
who is declining to speak Rowena chew
that's and she makes exactly the point
you did she talks about how you have to
understand we were all there and in
these compromised situations with him
where we were vulnerable to attacks
because he was charming and made you
feel like you could achieve your dreams
and was actually empowering in various
ways to women around him professionally
usually he'd say what do you want to do
do you want to be producer do want to be
a writer do you want to be a director
you know and you know I think that it's
really important to you know mention
that I'm always looking for ways to
debunk people that want to dismiss these
women in any ways well I'm you know it's
obvious why didn't they just leave
because it's so much more complicated
than that you know you get Stockholm
Syndrome with someone who's really
truculent and angry one minute and
really charming and engaging in the
other use of truculent you know it's
really it's really apt you know and you
know a lot of people listening might not
you know have a personal experience with
Harvey wines to news my guess if you're
listening but if you're listening you
probably know me a little bit and
I have a Harvey Weinstein story that
might just help people get a little bit
closer to this I did the Friars Club
roast of Quentin Tarantino and I show up
Brett Ratner is there
Harvey Weinstein is there just monsters
row of scumbag row Brett gets a little
cameo and he does yes he does and when
you talk about this being an open secret
like that word you know I try to get
even more granular with it it was not
only an open secret it was it was a it
was so we were so surrendered to this
that we actually made jokes about it it
was it was so crystallized his tentacles
were still crystallized across this
business that there was no option of
this ever being dismantled you know you
coming in it was you moved tectonic
plates that was something that was like
it never occurred to any of us that this
would ever change that he was Hollywood
well it was he's Vladimir Putin and we
are Russia that is what Harvey Weinstein
felt like in this business right it was
viewed as this unmovable part of the
culture and the industry but it's also
important to draw the distinction we
were talking about this before there's
knowing and then there's knowing that's
right that's right
and people lulled that people knew too
much but also not enough to force them
to understand oh we're making a catagory
error that's right you know these are
crimes that are happening mm-hmm so so
there was this okay we've normalized
transactional sex the casting couch and
it's you know we crack jokes about it
like you were joking about Tina Fey was
joking about upper-year you can find all
these clips of people joking about it
and it took these incredibly brave
sources coming forward and saying this
impossibly difficult thing which was
know he raped me yeah that's right
that's right and I think that
something's really important and why
it's necessary everybody read this book
and listen to the podcast is because I
think the word sexual assault you know
sexual harassment they're kind of a
Rorschach test you sort of come up with
what you think happened based on you
know whatever social construction in
your life or what's ever happened to you
or it all triggers a lot in us right
defense mechanisms or you know holds up
a mirror to whatever has happened to us
so a lot of you know I think people tend
to minimize those words the word rape
is a word people don't like to say it
makes everyone uncomfortable it's a
bummer
but this is really important to read
because it gets specific on what these
crimes were you know especially since
two years there's been a reckoning with
so many men I think a lot of people may
hear harassment they think like oh he
kept asking girls out that's not what
was happening that's not at all what was
happening these were violent crimes and
something else that is so important that
this book does because you know a lot of
people that want to assume there's this
like stereotype that it's every woman's
dream to like get assaulted so that they
can win that lotto payday or something
and cash out like women are just getting
in line to get assaulted so that they
can you know retire these sources we now
know because of your reporting or
trepidatious many did not want to
participate there's this idea that women
are like chomping at the bit to come out
against these men it's a living
nightmare and that's something that is
very apparent and that was part of
Harvey Weinstein's response through all
of this this idea that these events were
being opportunistically recast by women
out to make a buck or increase their
profile or somehow get revenge or
something
it just never squared with the reality
of my experiences working with those
sources which was I had to bang on doors
for months yet and and hopefully to it
in a way that also even though I knew it
was terrifying for these people gave
them the space to make the decision
forcing them to but boy were they ever
not crying it from the mountaintops I
think that they really went through an
agonizing process of deciding whether
they were gonna upend their entire lives
to tell these stories and they weave a
slate sometimes they were in and then
they were out and then they were back in
and then they needed more time and I
mean Rose McGowan is a great example and
her story runs through the book and
honestly like I don't know that I would
have been in a more stable place than
Rose if I were going through what Rose
was going through which it comes to pass
was she was being gas-lit and there were
spies after her and her new best friend
turned out to be an Israeli spy you guys
have acting you have to read that I mean
literally Harvey had
our company to send a woman to befriend
her pretend she was a part of some
women's rights organization all just in
order to procure passages from her
forthcoming book to get it back to
Harvey literally yeah where Rose at one
point says you're the only person I can
trust I am I can't trust anyway I can't
trust my lawyer she's like they're you
know recording like putting her wrist
with a recording device forward to send
all of this to Rose's alleged rapist I
can't believe it it's not not a great
thing to do epically it turns out what
accent is that case baa nanna case my
products I love Casper you know I have a
cast from YouTube love Casper they're
cleverly designed to mimic human curves
of which I have a plenty right supports
all kinds of bodies I love this its body
inclusive you spend one third of your
life sleeping nice any more problems I
don't I never spent a day in your life
people love sleeping experts are cast
gasma work tightly to make sure the
quality sleep surface Oh quality sleep
see I don't sleep enough I need a I need
a Casper so that I can actually read the
Casper copy it cradles your natural
geometry and all the right places what
my natural just describing people like
that grow that natural geometry you have
the original Casper mattress combines
multiple supportive memory foams for
quality sleep services with the right
amounts of both sink and bounce you do
need my personality you need breathable
design helps you sleep cool and
regulates your body temperature that is
the key to everything isn't yeah that is
I love that it doesn't get too hot these
mattresses you can be sure of your
purchase with Casper's 100 night
risk-free sleep on it trial wow that's a
Power Move that's amazing I think we
need to talk about the hybrid which
combines the pressure relief of
award-winning foam foam that's what I'm
into with durable yet gentle springs
that's what you are you're durable yet
gentle yeah the best part of the
countermeasure so is it showed up in a
box that's by far the best do you member
when you
go to him like an animal on top of your
car and like drive to the city with your
mattress that's disgusting Wow get $100
towards select mattresses by visiting
chaos but calm / Whitney and using
Whitney at checkout so Casper calm /
Whitney terms and conditions apply it's
a female founded feminine care brand my
favorite sentence I've ever said
offering high quality period and sexual
wellness products made with natural
ingredients finally someone freaking did
this Lola's tampons pads liners and
cleansing wipes are all made with 100%
organic cotton no toxins no synthetic
fibers never been easier to try Lola
right never easier are you gonna read
some of this yeah but you haven't got to
the point on both to read yet no Lola
believes in total ingredient
transparency did you know the FDA does
not require brands to disclose
comprehensive list of ingredients in
their feminine care products which is
probably why stutter and just said
comprehensive because I had tampons in
the 90s when they were full of hormones
chemicals and crap that's why big brands
often use disclaimers like may contain
because they're sketchy
Lola makes period products with 100%
organic cotton most brands use a mix of
synthetic and just garbage and plastic
and rayon and bullshit Lola products
they are made with 100% organic cotton
never any toxins dyes fragrances
synthetic fibers or chlorine bleach
yeah.well also offers to trial sets each
featuring a mix of sort of period
products made from 100% organic cotton
for just $5 both sets includes six
compact plastic applicator tampons one
light two regular two supreme and one
super plus I love with either two old
custom liners and two cleansing wipes I
love this brand I love not putting
poison in my body it's never been easier
to try Lola get started with trial set
today
give me a 30% off your 5 dollar trial
set visit my lola commenter whitney
redeem your offer and don't get cancer
[Music]
this Harvey store you know just for
people listening you know I I just you
have a personal connection to me maybe
so let me just tell you the story just
so you get an idea of the way this guy
operated and I didn't put this together
until way later but I do the roasts I
have so many jokes about Harvey
Weinstein that are just brutal again it
was the people laughed at it I mean I
did jokes like Harvey slept with so many
actresses he doesn't have the clap he
has the applause I mean I was doing
jokes like that I mean of course none of
us knew that these were right rapes
right of course you know I stood a joke
that was like Harvey's slept with so
many actresses backstage Wes took out ad
space on his taint
I remember hearing you make that choice
that was a joke
that I just made and everybody laughed
you know and you know with girlfriends
we would literally sit around and you
know a friend of mine was doing a Harvey
movie and we go bring your kneepads like
that's how resigned everyone was true
that's how ubiquitous this was so I do
the roasts that night we go to dinner
it's like me and Quentin and whatever
everyone in Harvey's there and I don't
really remember talking to him but we
were kind of sitting near each other all
I remember is that he made the table
laugh so hard he was telling these big
stories and cracking everybody up and it
was just like so charismatic so engaging
funny smart of course Lee vicious quick
remembered everybody's names you know
he's like Whitney how's your sushi like
he was just really really quick
incredible brain and then the next day I
get a call for an audition for a Harvey
Weinstein movie and this is a movie that
I don't I don't know if it ever existed
I get a call for a Harvey Weinstein
movie I'm like I don't like I don't have
the site I'm not that they're like the
sides will be there when you get there
which is very abnormal that's very
unusual normally you get sides sent to
you before but this is like I'm 24 years
old I don't know what's going on I'm
like okay is our army wide see movie
everyone is very stressed out that's
calling me about it whenever Harvey was
involved in anything people were doing
yeah you know you gotta go to this
reading and I'm like what can I do it
tomorrow and he gotta go today and
everyone's like I've never seen agents
or anyone behave like this before so I
go to this place I'm really nervous
because it's I usually you could
prepare before an audition I walk into
this in look this may be me being
paranoid but I have cast things since so
I now know how casting is supposed to
work I now know that casting offices
have like furniture and desks and people
and chairs I walked into this office I
just remember going oh they must have
just moved in but it was a totally empty
room with no chairs there wasn't a
tripod and a camera set up most audition
rooms have like lights there's a piece
of blue paper in the background
normally the actor gets miked it's it's
there's other actors in the waiting room
I shop it's just me and the casting
director is like I had never met before
it's kind of frazzled and like forcing
me to like read this thing and it's just
filming me with a camera in her hand
like there I've never had an audition
before that or since and I look back and
I don't know if it was a real audition
or not I don't know but I went in and
then later they're like oh the movies
probably not happening or they haven't
gotten finding what were the sides it
was something about a babysitter I think
that's a lot just Harvey Wednesday
writing two paragraphs just gave me a
book to read more I just read Hornby's
know I don't I don't remember cuz it was
a movie that never came out and they
were like oh it lost financing cuz I
that was the time worms like you know I
wanted a job so I mean that did happen a
lot obviously I happens in general a lot
but it especially happened a lot around
Harvey in those days I I didn't put it
together no joke till your article came
out I was like that probably wasn't even
a real audition because and then I sort
of did the math on it
but I know I don't know for sure and
then the next day I want to say to Dame
it was like two days later I'm at The
Comedy Store and performing the Comedy
Store I go on stage and I remember the
set being weird because I was wearing
like sneaker wedges and I like fell a
little bit so I ended up just like sort
of joking around with the audience the
whole time I left I get a call ten
minutes later from the manager of the
Comedy Store who is no longer the
manager the comedy star so no one's
getting in trouble here currently and he
was a get back here Harvey Weinstein
came to see you and I've known this man
for 10 years he was shrieking I mean
this Harvey Weinstein is a man that
terrified men that needed nothing from
him I mean this was a a great
a brusque comedy club owner who had C
you know who carries drunk people out of
comedy clubs that are trying to fight
him you know he's get back here right
screaming at me and just picturing
Harvey sitting there you know having
come to see me and wanting to get me
back I didn't go back because no joke I
was too insecure because I wasn't
wearing makeup and I was like I can't
let Harvey without makeup like my vanity
probably saved me but this just for
people listening like this is a man that
like hunted people yeah hunted people a
lot of sources used that word you know
this wasn't like a oh we were kind of
flirting and then we both had different
ideas of what happened afterwards this
is a man that went after women bang down
their doors women are putting furniture
in front of their doors this is a this
is Darth Vader this is a cartoon villain
it's and it's such a crazy experience as
a reporter to have multiple women
independently describe these eerily
similar things women who have never
spoken to each other
mm-hmm will just tell the identical
story of and then I pushed the furniture
in front of the doors you know I know it
sounds crazy it was like in a movie that
I was so scared
and and the traits you're talking about
all inform each other they're of a piece
he was a bully it is ultimately a story
about the abuse of power and the fact
that when we are afraid to question
people at the top of whatever industry
sometimes people get hurt as a result
because that's what unchecked power can
do yeah you know it's just so
fascinating to be in a business that
makes all its money from making movies
about taking down villains no one could
figure out how to do it when it was
happening in real life it's like a bunch
of writers and producers that are all
like making movies about how to take
down a villain I'm like just do what
would your character in the script you
just wrote do about this guy we don't
even know how to write those movies all
the movies end with a giant column of
light now a lot of people flying around
in a column of light I mean this is a
man who what what was the AM for did he
steal six hundred thousand dollars from
aids so there was this controversy on
the board of amphoras you know where
funds were allegedly being redirected
from the charity to
the production of Finding Neverland yeah
Broadway version of Finding Neverland I
was doing and I think his explanation
was that it was sort of designed to be
joint fundraising but it was certainly
it was regarded as shady yeah
within this board and now as he's
working overtime to suppress these
allegations of sexual abuse against and
he's also trying to get the m4 far board
to sign these crazy non-disclosure
agreements and to kind of pay them out
to get rid of that problem yeah and
eventually the house of cards does you
know start to topple it's so important
how many things that this you know
debunks like and how many things that
came up that that enraged me you know
I'm obsessed with the things people say
in order to kind of like get around
having to confront sexual harassment and
I know it's a big thing and sometimes we
have to disassociate or sometimes we
have to kind of you know I was talking
to someone about one of these and
they're like hold this come on oh that
was 20 years ago and it's so wild to me
and people say that cuz I'm like listen
you're basically like oh like that we
weren't denial 20 years ago now we have
to be in denial again like this is
exhausting like think about what you're
saying well there's this conversation
now about how we should feel about time
when it comes to serious crimes and
there's all these jurisdictions saying
you know what we're gonna get rid of the
statute of limitations when it comes to
sexual assault and I think that's a
pretty healthy conversation and any when
you say this happened 20 years ago all I
think is think of all the people it's
happened to since listen to what you're
saying and that is such a big part of
the motivation as so many of the people
who ultimately spoke this the
realization that whether it was just of
their own volition staying quiet because
they were justifiably frightened about
repercussions for them or they signed
some kind of a crazy non-disclosure
agreement it took a payout I think for
those people realizing that others were
getting hurt while they grappled with
the weight of silence yes
changed everything and now that it's
been a couple years since the first New
Yorker article came out now there's no
you cannot hold on to that logic anymore
there's no one who has come forward
whose life has magically got an
amazingly better like they're really
martyrs and do
this for the next generation of women
and to protect others like you don't
come out and then all of a sudden you
like get to start Marvel movies I think
both things are true it's been hard for
a number of these women particularly in
Hollywood who spoken these stories and a
lot of them still talk about not getting
any work they haven't gotten a single
audition since the story I hear those
kinds of accounts after the fact but
there's also definitely a contingent
that's doing great and I think that's
important to note as well because the
fears loomed so large and I have loved
as the reporter in that equation having
people come back and say you know what I
feel a huge weight lifted and look it's
complicated for all of them but a lot of
them have said it's better now and some
of them even you know their careers have
been fine or better than I've felt less
paralyzed by this they're able to work
more well I think it's that I think it's
just sort of the weight off their
shoulders and this sort of healing
moment it's not like you know for people
that think that this would be some kind
of a career move or some kind of
mercenary certainly not that thank you
for attention
if you know the women that are thriving
because of it is you know because
they're healing and because they're
moving past something and because the
sort of evil powers that were you know
smearing them are now gone yeah yeah and
look it in those cases which I wish were
more common where someone feels like
their career has been in a good place
since they did an incredibly brave thing
I came a source in a contentious story I
wish every industry would do more of
that you know there are a couple of
cases like an agent I used to work with
I mean you should get credit for this
Bryan lourd and his folks at CAA called
Annabella she aura you know right after
she did this incredibly difficult thing
of coming forward with a very very
violent by the way it's really important
for you know this is someone who's when
you first called said no thank you
not interested oh yeah and did you what
did you feel when she said that she was
apologizing for not being able to help
in a way that made you think that made
me think that there was more there and
also I had heard from so many people
that she had told this story
consistently over the years but
ultimately when someone is completely
shut down
like that there's nothing you can do but
give them space right and thank God she
then reconsidered later and and her
story I think has really inspired a lot
of people it's it's a particularly
brutal and awful one and I think anyone
who reads it or hears it will understand
why she was reluctant to speak at first
heartbreaking embarrassing that's that
that I think a lot of people don't
understand that that it's no one's
dreamed to go out in the world and have
everybody know something that intimate
about you what she did is is heroic she
now has to walk down the street and
everybody knows this awful thing
happened to her and she talked about
that she went into the decision eyes
open and you know I think she's one of
the people where the degree of trauma
she went through is so severe that there
are good days and bad days and none of
it is easy even in an ongoing sense and
so it's been a wonderful thing that you
know I career-wise it's not easy either
and she's supporting her kids but you
know she did get new representation
afterwards and people in the industry
rallied around her a little bit and you
know she's been working again at which
which is also great as a consumer of
movies cuz she's a wonderful Harvey it
also was after you know sexually
assaulting her was telling everyone she
was difficult yeah you know he put
people in an impossible situation he
would assault them then tell everyone
they were difficult and then make it so
it was impossible to get any kind of
legal action and then were forced to
sign these ndas that made them always
have to look over their shoulder and be
paranoid completely and I really hope
that pulling back the curtain on that
and understanding that that was a real
thing that was happening the
blacklisting and the smearing yeah opens
doors for I know it sounds like a movie
you know it sounds like a movie but
these things were actually happening
well and when you talk to smart people
who went through it of course the first
thing they say is I know I'll never be
able to prove this I remember Mira
Sorvino who's incredibly intelligent and
grounded yeah saying you know look I'm
gonna be intellectually honest about
this I know when I say this everyone's
just gonna say oh she you know she aged
out of those parts whatever
heartbreaking but then it wasn't true
you know Peter Jackson came out and said
very very helpful for the culture that
he did at came out
said you know oh no I was gonna cast her
in Lord of the Rings and then Harvey
Weinstein said she's difficult so it was
a real thing that was happening you do
address an elf in the living room that I
think it's important to talk about I
address into my last special because I
think it just lets people take a deep
breath when we acknowledge that you know
we expect victims to also be Saints I
believe is how you put it we expect our
victims to sort of be perfect and dress
frumpy and to never have done a sex
scene before and we want our victims to
be a very certain way and look most
people are flawed and I'm no math elite
but by that logic victims will have
flaws and will have pass and have made
mistakes and to you know bring up what
happened with hacia am I saying that
right I think is really important just
because it helps us just with the
elephant the living room because I think
for people that are trying to warm out
of the discomfort of talking about this
or believing that this is happening or
who are struggling with you know a major
reorganization of sort of global
institutions and paradigms they want to
go see Yaffe and look even if you do
need to that to delete that there's
still what 86 other women right but was
that something when that happened that
you were like move or it's just it is
what it is
you know I chose in the book to confront
that completely head-on and as you say I
think it's a really important point that
can be too hard to talk about sometimes
these are not perfect people they're
human beings very often in a case like
that someone like OCR Gento both having
a completely credible claim of abuse
about Harvey Weinstein that was backed
by a lot of evidence and also then
paying out a you know a guy who was 17
at the time after he claimed that they
had had an underage sexual encounter
that's not inconsistent psychologically
that right people who have been preyed
upon then sometimes are also people who
are accused of these kinds of crimes
that'll hurt people
yeah is it's you know an old idea and a
true one
and in a case like that you know there
are no absolutes and these stories
shouldn't be about broad character
judgments they should be about the fact
pattern that Jack and I run into it all
the time in the earlier reporting - with
someone like Rose McGowan where very
unfairly to her you know all these
executives were constantly saying but
she's crazy she sounds crazy and here's
the thing
first of all roses not crazy she turned
out to be right about all this stuff but
I was constantly making the argument and
I think it's a really correct one and a
journalistically important one that
someone being having the appearance of
instability in other parts of their life
not being the ideal witness in the way
that you were ability I don't know what
was that I don't know Kahneman I've
heard about it that is not germane to
whether their claim holds up necessarily
you know that my judgement about roses
allegation was about how many people had
seen her come out of that room how had
she told the story consistently over the
years what did the documents she had in
terms of this settlement she had with
Harvey Weinstein looked like you know
the whole trail of witnesses and
corroborating pieces of evidence and
that all held up and so to then say you
know this person isn't an ideal witness
or doesn't present in a way that we like
so we're gonna throw out all that
evidence is is wrong it son journalistic
and it opens the door to all of these
things like you know slut-shaming mental
health shame you know it it becomes
character driven and smear based rather
than fact driven you know and I think
it's important for people who do want to
say things like that examine why you
know she did some nude scenes okay
there's that you know she dated Marilyn
Manson there's that that we do sort of
hold in our hippocampus a couple things
that you know conflate and make some
generalization so that we can dismiss
someone so I think you know it's a good
opportunity to sort of you know
illuminate your own cultural sort of
conditioning and prejudices when we do
want to you know call a woman crazy who
who comes forward that's just worth
examining well and also you know without
referring to Rose specifically so often
in
of sexual violence you are dealing with
people who either were on some level
more vulnerable to this kind of
exploitation because they had a
difficult background or because of their
state of mental health who then as a
result in part of this incredible moment
of trauma of further suffer in terms of
their mental health and so they're not
always going to present in this
picture-perfect way also I mean I was in
real damage there and I can say this you
probably can't like she was raised in a
cult I mean the girl she comes from what
she was upright in roses case-specific
she had a very very difficult back
pretty same given the circumstances she
is sharp as a tack and you know was was
so much more right about these
circumstances than any of the naysayers
and you know I just think that's a
really important conversation to talk
about the way we want our victims to
behave the way we want our victims to
appear the way we want them to look the
way we want their you know their work to
have been and you know this was not just
you know hot actresses either you know I
think that that rose already you know
having done nude scenes and stuff we
have to understand a lot of these women
are were targets because of that reason
because they were women that you know
wouldn't have the resources to defend
themselves would already have the cards
stacked against them we're already
vulnerable in some way you know so it's
it's not you know lost on Harvey that
that's a really easy target who can't
defend herself it's a conversation I've
had with a number of sources in those
stories where they they have theorized
that that's part of why they were
targeted in the first place that they
betrayed some kind of vulnerability and
but it was not just actresses I mean
this was costume designers suits were
producers these were event planners
these were assistants you know these you
know for people that want to think of
actress as a pejorative term of a woman
who wants attention or whatever sort of
narrative you have in your head these
were not just actresses you know I think
that's the very first vignette in the
very first of The New Yorker Weinstein
stories was about a woman who's not even
in the industry all of those stories
have a mix of famous people not famous
people and and more than that I think
what made me so convinced that this
story matter
was that these patterns didn't seem
exclusive to Harvey Weinstein or even to
Hollywood right it's about the abuse of
power which unfolds in the industry
after industry but you really you know
it's fascinating i as I was reading this
I was like god we really do need our
victims to behave in a very specific way
you know especially with the Matt Lauer
stuff which you know the Matt Lauer
stuff is is truly mind-blowing it's this
this man got me through 9/11 it's it you
know I think before this book it was
really hard to understand what this was
you know because I think people are so
afraid to say the word rape it's so
uncomfortable to say it's such a bummer
to say that you know we say there were
sexual assault and then people fill in
the blanks of what happened um and the
and the I believe it's two women who
really had explicit rape allegations
against Lauer they did such a difficult
thing such a difficult thing and I feel
like I'm qualified to be able to say
that you know a lot of people on ago
will they text it afterwards you know I
think it's really important that people
understand psychologically when someone
has committed a violent act against you
a lot of times it is your instinct to
keep yourself safe and to placate the
person to ameliorate the situation you
know you know so I think just for anyone
that wants to go but they the girl
texted with him afterwards how could
anything bad have happened you know well
one of the things that these sources
have done that's so valuable for all of
us and our understanding of these issues
is to talk in a completely candid and
honest way warts-and-all about what
those interactions look like and one of
those two rape allegations is from a
woman who talked to the New York Times
one of them is from a young journalist
named Brooke nevels he ends up playing a
major role in in this book and she
really has done us all a service I think
in being very very transparent about the
whole process the fact that she was too
drunk to consent by her account and then
also said no to a specific sex act and
he went ahead with it anyway that it was
embedded in this situation where he was
the most powerful guy at a comp
that she was striving to succeed in and
and a man who was just sorry to bring
this back with the Harvey Weinstein's
funny a man who I mean we've both been
on around him a lot he's engaging he's
charismatic he looks everyone in the eye
he shakes everyone's hand remaining
handsome guys love this I mean he's
literally got us through 9/11 well and I
since this is a kind of a memoir as well
I'm upfront about the fact that he was
something of a mentor to me and someone
I looked up to and who gave me advice
and was supportive of my work and so I
mean a couple of things one is someone
like Brooke nevels being transparent not
only about this allegation of violent
crime which is difficult enough to talk
about but then also about the way in
which in the aftermath of something like
that there is a process of wanting to
convince the powerful guy that you're
afraid of that everything is okay yep
because you're scared for your career
but also even more complicatedly
wanting to convince yourself that's
right it's something that she talks
about that she went through a period
after that of desperately wanting to say
this incident that made me literally
bleed for days that was so upsetting to
me maybe maybe it can be okay yes and
and also you're you know when you decide
that you know a survivor should behave a
certain way after they're attacked
you're judging someone's trauma response
I mean some of us are fight some or
flight' some are freeze it is a very
strong fight response to go placate the
attacker make things less dangerous for
yourself or you're in some kind of
denial or disassociated and everything's
fine everything's got to be fine you
know and to be clear you know this isn't
I think the thing were all afraid of
which is you know recategorize in the
facts recasting what happened she has
always been consistent in describing the
fact pattern but she also acknowledges
that for a time afterwards she she
wanted there to be some some other thing
a consensual respectful rapport and then
there were subsequent encounters that
she also says were non-consensual at
which point she she did ultimately
months later just say I can't anymore
yeah but that's a really complicated
situation not the initial incident but
the aftermath that's right
and I again I think she does us all a
service by talking about it so openly I
think so too and I think a lot of women
you know don't come forward about stuff
because of their own behavior afterwards
you know like well I'm the one that's
screwed up because I texted back with an
exclamation mark so Who am I to victim
you know so I think that's incredibly
important I'm gonna ask you some sort of
you know speed round questions when
Harvey called you and he said the
cartoon villain line of you couldn't
save someone you love so now you want to
save everyone such an ominous it's it's
bad writing so much there are so many
cases in this without reviewing sources
and methods on any one given scene you
know there's an author's note up front
saying basically when you hear a direct
quote it's it's from some authoritative
source that's neither a primary account
or recording or whatever and there are
so many cases in the reporting for this
book writ large where there is just such
over written movie dialogue and then you
know the fact checker literally listens
to the audio of it it's like wow people
really said that shit and you know there
I guess there is something that happens
when you're in the midst of these
heightened events where everyone does
start talking like they're in a Marvel
movie or just like conversations about
destiny and family in my case it was
particularly weird because that line
wasn't even that surprising because for
months Harvey Weinstein had been sending
legal threat letters that were all about
my pedophile uncle who I'd never met and
my sister having been assaulted yeah and
it made an allegation against a powerful
guy you know all of this sort of stuff
that never was convincingly germane to
the reporting in any way but I guess was
just designed it's just undercut and
upset me and you know convince my bosses
that in some way I was compromised too
close to it actually all terms that get
directed at my women sources all the
time yeah it's too emotional he's too
close to it but it became very
personalized and and I've come to
understand that's a little bit just part
of the weirdness of this job that every
story
or there was an effort to attack not
only the sources but also me and to do
so in as personal away as possible
did that line now at all feel like he
was implying that Woody Allen's guilty
you couldn't I would assume he doesn't
know anything more that I probably he
knows less than the average person who
looks at the actual court records
because in in the events of this
reporting he gets in touch with Woody
Allen and then like his credit-card
receipts show him purchasing a sort of
Pro Woody Allen book by Woody Allen fan
laying out all the arguments you know
that my sister was crazy or brainwashed
basically started doing research taking
a page out of Woody Allen's playbook in
order to figure out how to deal with you
right very very strange and not that
effective tech although he did manage to
get me fired over it so it worked for a
little while I'm sorry I have a little
rant that you probably can't participate
it is when can we just say that Woody
Allen's movies aren't that good can at
some point can someone just say one out
of every four movies is good because he
cast someone cate blanchett of course
that movie's gonna be good Joaquin
Phoenix but I his movies are fucking
boring I'm sorry there I you can just
it's just it's always like gorgeous
women in Olive cargo shorts like
sleeping with married guys I don't need
to see more rich women in the Upper East
Side fighting I'm good
Kathy Griffin told this story at Largo
once it's now in her book about how she
had dinner with Woody Allen oh yeah this
is at I think Gloria Vanderbilt's house
and Woody Allen wouldn't first of all
wouldn't talk to her which is so great
when comics won't talk to comics like
there's just it's just so bizarre and
she was just like pulling teeth trying
to get him to talk to her he wasn't he I
don't think even knew who she was and he
asked he wouldn't talk to her and she
asked him what his favorite TV show was
I remember this from her any guesses
what the answer was Benten I read the
book but I can't remember Hannah Montana
oh good one that's woody allen's
favorite favorite TV show are we fucking
done here can we move on please
you're cancelled I'm good it's just like
I'm good yuck
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a genius company that you're
gonna need because of its engagement
season everyone's getting engaged I'm
sure you've seen them on your Instagram
everyone's blessed they're highly
favored they're bragging about their
engagement their journey
I think it's engagement season because
it's holiday time and everybody actually
has time to propose but they're telling
me that according to a zola survey 96%
of couples think the planning their
wedding was stressful yet yes think an
86% suffered stress induced symptoms
like insomnia breakouts and lower sex
drive that totally happened to me
starting to plan a wedding made me so
anxious I started breaking out and I was
like I love you but I cannot get sits
over this so I was actually so
overwhelmed that we actually kind of
held off on digging right in because
Ruben was just like the logistics the
registry and the RSVPs and the I just I
started getting super overwhelmed so I
wish I had known about Zola but now I do
I wish I had known that you have to book
venues in advance I wish I had known you
have to get like a website now and I
don't know I just this company is
freaking awesome because they make
wedding planning easier less stressful
with wedding websites registries invites
they have a guest list manager all in
one place they have free website designs
you heard me I said free website designs
highest rated registry of all time
speaks for itself
beautiful affordable invites and paper
they're gonna help you collect your
addresses track online RSVP this is like
having a wedding planner Jesus because
they have a guest list manager Zola has
helped 1 million couples get married wow
that's amazing sign up for Zola dot-com
slash Whitney today and get your free
personalized paper sample use code save
55 oh and get 50% off your save the
dates that Zola dot-com / Whitney promo
code save 50 do it girls say I do to
Zola I just come up with her slogan
so this book is harrowing the fact that
you were being followed first of all
it's so funny to me that these former
Mossad agents this black cube I mean
sounds like I mean like literally a
Marvel movie version the spy company
would be called black cube first of all
the fact that they were following the
wrong person because there was someone
in your building that looked like you I
would love to see that guy I want to get
his no yeah and I have the pictures to
keep they were surveilling him and
ultimately well I don't want to spoil
the whole lot but I get a hold about
their surveillance material and he
didn't look that much like whenever
someone's like this person looks like
you it always hurts my feelings well I
think my I have to go back to the
pictures but I think my anxiety when I
saw that material was in the city the
what was this Samantha's boyfriend it
was probably him I I think they were
following a better looking group the
fact that in 2019 almost 2020 that
journalists are being followed
intimidated stalked gas-lit how it's not
great it's not you know I've now done a
lot of reporting on this sort of
underbelly of the private intelligence
world and I think it's an industry that
has perfectly valid applications but
also needs to do a really hard
reassessment of where they're ethical
red lines I mean is the onus on the
companies such as NBC to protect its
journalists I would have loved to felt
more protected and not been cut loose
and fired in the middle of being on the
run but you know in NBC's defense they
do have a security department and I did
I went to that security department while
I was still employed there and it's not
really incumbent on news organizations
to stop this kind of aggressive
surveillance I think that news
organizations can help by breaking tough
stories
of this type and that with all of that
reporting could have come out at NBC and
I think the fact that the New Yorker put
out the reporting exposing that
espionage operation helps create
accountability right but that's indirect
I think on the the kind of the direct
front the criminal justice system can
play a role and there there is an active
criminal investigation into this
particular surveillance operation and
it's a plot point in the book that I
have to grapple with whether to become a
witness in that process I mean the fact
that the DEA did not press charges after
you had this Ramin for Arbor's recording
which in the podcast you have delicious
recording it is so bone-chilling and
sickening and angering isn't she a woman
not only wore a wire around this you
know cartoon monster known for being
truculent but she like a gangster had to
destroy all the recordings and made a
backup recording that she like made a
fake email and sent it to herself it's
so cool it's so cool she did everything
right and she's salt and she got you
know she is and like she took the payout
uh and figured out a way to get the
evidence out and completely screw him
anyway and create accountability oh
waited like the DA's office and all of
his security right even when the DA's
office was completely crooked about this
yeah that was the consensus of even a
lot of people on in the NYPD who were
involved in this issue they had charges
on much less that's the argument that
the cops made and the DA's office says
you know they have a lot of elaborate
explanations but in my view very few of
them hold water and they should be held
accountable for not pressing charges in
that case because other people allegedly
got hurt afterwards but amber Gutierrez
saved the day on that and preserved the
evidence and she ultimately got it to me
in such a skillful deft way I loved
hearing her story after the fact when
she finally was out of the woods and
could talk about it more and I hope
people have the same reaction when it's
it's like really it's thrilling and then
it is even more thrilling because you're
like this actually happened
like it's entertaining on its own and
then it's thrilling also just seeing
someone who's that
conscientious and ethical I mean she had
she was smeared and made out to be a
hustler huh
and a hooker and you know I had all
these conversations but I can say this
is this was an on-the-record quote we
have heard you know David Boies for
instance would say you know well she's a
hooker and David Boies is Harvey
Weinstein's lawyer super kind of
high-profile celebrity lawyers yeah
democratic hero argued all these big
cases trash I mean did not acquit
himself shall we say in the most noble
of ways representing Harvey Weinstein
and going after his victims but he and
everyone else in the orbit of this story
just wrote her off and worse smeared her
and actually she did again a perfect
target yeah a perfect target you know
because a lingerie model she barely
spoke English who's gonna believe her
but but she's an interesting
counterpoint actually to a lot of the
very very vulnerable people who I think
were then subject to arguments that they
were unstable in some way that say she
had all these spurious arguments about
her character and reputation and her
sexual past thrown at her but amber
Gutierrez is fascinating to me because
she's actually so nailed down yeah and
so stable calm and as her shit so
together that she just ran circles
around all these people and that's not
to say that it was easy for her or that
it wasn't traumatic but she is an
impressive example of someone who
actually held way more of the cards than
anyone brought its 22 year old lingerie
model that hardly spoke English yes like
clown and on everybody yeah and you can
hear in the tape I mean this is the the
framing that we used in the podcast
episode where we tell her story you can
hear when you know her fuller story that
she's actually playing him she goes back
in for that police sting right and and
she you know it's she wins in the end
like she it's it puts it made me have
goosebumps because you know she had to
go upstairs with him it was a
last-minute surprise and she left her
coat on purpose so that she could go
back and get
like it's really and she says such a
striking thing about that which is so
also a reflection of how insightful she
is I say to her because I guess misogyny
and even I underestimate her like oh is
that a thing that the cops told you to
do and she's like oh she's like no
that's because I'm a woman and my mother
always taught me you need an escape
route that's right and I mean in my
defense I thought I had been told by
others in the investigators tried to
take credit for that but what she said
and I was I it's such a memorable moment
was you know my mom always told me
you're a woman you need a way out at all
times and that she came up with that
idea of you leave a jacket behind
strategically so powerfully it's just
like I was like literally on the plane
and I was like squealing and you know
one of the great things built into her
story which you don't get in all cases
but I love running into it when it does
happen is she's doing great yeah her
modeling career is doing great she's on
catwalks everywhere she's doing you know
commercial shoots all the time and seems
to be sooo podcasts in the world behind
only Jo rope so the the podcasts
incredible you got a you have got to
listen to it it is so gripping and it's
so fun to listen at the same time as
they come out while I was reading this I
had such a nice time being able to put
like voices and faces to the few
characters I know I've told you go soon
I refuse you're gonna be kicking it this
is not consensual times up on me I will
stay for you because I would have what
else do I'm gonna do speed round
question yes a lot of people want to
know I don't know I can't I feel weird
asking this because I don't want your
expression to let anything a lot of
people
Epstein comes up in the book there's
some you're reading this book and you
think you're just reading about
Weinstein and then there's just like
banger after banger like right at the
finish line it's like Trump Epstein damn
there's so much but Epstein you know
comes up is there more to come with
Epstein so I broke a story about MIT a
secret fundraising relationship with
Epstein pretty recently he is a great
example of a nexus of powerful interests
protecting each other and
covering up there are close connections
and I do think that there is more to dig
into there which is just important
because you know this is not a American
that the more money you have the more
you can just cover up your heinous
crimes you know this is to be
dismantling the systems that allow
powerful people to just break the law
I mean sadly that is the most American
thing and I think we all need to work
hard to change that and I hope that one
of the consequences of these incredibly
brave sources speaking I mean that in
that case again it was a woman named
Sidney Swenson who saved all of the
emails of literally people in leadership
roles at MIT saying please cover up this
app Steve they're like this needs to be
under the radar please make sure this is
quiet email right subject line epstein
money I mean it's I was right I was
finishing the book and like about to
start doing press for it and the you
know champagne problem to have but the
trouble you you've had to juggle this
stuff when you're pushing a both
Pulitzer Prizes yeah okay okay when
you're pushing a book you're not doing
new work so you're looking backwards and
so I was in this frustrating period
where I'm like okay now I need to buckle
down and just focus on this book for a
couple of months and then this lead came
in and I wasn't even sure like Epstein
MIT in a Julie K Brown did such amazing
work on Epstein and how is there really
more to say I mean I was asking the
question that you just asked me and then
seeing those emails I was like well
better drop everything and just do this
story right away do you think you killed
himself
you know I think that even the most
innocuous scenario of this is the kind
of negligence that happens all the time
in the prison system and gets covered up
is is pretty worthy of note and and look
I I do think that it's worth journalists
pressing for more answers about what
went down there and how and when we were
finishing the book
and writing the epstein parts I had to
decide what language to use around his
suicide and I think you know and we
looked at okay what is the the post
saying what is the time saying that I
think ultimately we hedged a little I
think it's you know dead of an apparent
suicide mm-hmm too much it's too much
it's too do you put extra you put it's a
very exact area you put anything in
email are you super paranoid about what
you can put on email do you have like
five cell phones yeah I don't want to
get into all of the security stuff I do
but there you know I can say what I say
in the book which is at a certain point
in this process I do get in pretty deep
with some whistleblower attorneys who
kind of furnished me with a ipod that's
only connected to the Internet through a
Wi-Fi hotspot that was purchased in cash
and yeah I have like a code name on it
which initially was candy maybe
literally anything at the time was like
what I I sound like a nice Midwestern
girl II shouldn't have moved to LA Andy
okay I feel like yeah
I also love that in the Guardian they
refer to John Lovett is your
long-suffering partner is that was that
a quote from me yeah I was like I need
to read some article just to make sure
that I'm like up on everything that was
like in his long-suffering partner I
mean that does sound like something I
would also say and also is fairly
accurate I am I knew - are so perfectly
matched I think I think if you were
around any more any more available he
probably I'm busy I mean in his defense
I think it's hard to finish this book
and not feel like wow sympathies to jump
culpable oh yeah yeah he is not better
roses all the time Peter
here's a lot of work I mean we're both
very high maintenance people is the long
and short of it that's correct
everyone wants to know when you're
getting married are you ready to talk
about it yet or no yeah it's funny I
gave an interview I'm I mean we should
be so lucky I mean correct if you guys
can afford me I'll think about it oh my
god you probably do perform at wedding I
get asked to perform to officiate
weddings lot I officiated one wedding
and I can't hold it so I am it I am what
it's called what is it I'm a priest what
am I like a unitary what is it when
you're a minister I got the online
certification and they did get divorced
a year later cool so my average is
pretty good we gotta wake work on your
sales pitch I did this interview as we
were launching the podcast where I
talked about all this you know the
substance of these incredible sources
who were speaking for the first time in
the podcast yeah before us and we talked
about that for half an hour and then it
was People magazine and this lovely
gentleman from People magazine then said
like have you planned the wedding
are you planning the wedding yet and I
you know just a tiny little answer at
the end I said honest to god I'm so
overwhelmed by work right now we haven't
even thought about it and it's gonna be
so busy for 2020 political stuff like
when are we supposed to do this damn
wedding yeah maybe it's a 2021 thing and
then the People magazine ahead light is
is the most people take on it ever it's
like just headline like Ronan Farrow too
busy to play his with people I cannot no
I did mention the podcast lowdown it was
like four paragraphs of wedding coverage
I really do feel like this is gonna be a
real competition with the vows oh god
now well so I actually it would not be a
shock to anyone who knows my biography
to hear that I don't really have like
the most positive associations with the
institution of marriage and maybe
long-term relationships in general it's
talking a little natural skepticism
there so I also similarly don't stand on
ceremony about it and feel like why not
just get a low but I think he thinks his
mother will yeah yeah have a conniption
made
with you and I think that's fair of her
kreso you could do both also yeah yeah
I'm planning you guys I'm planning this
wedding I got it I honestly just get it
done for us Whitney I know that you have
more industries to go dismantle and to
topple we didn't even get to the war on
peace this book I is so important for so
many reasons that I'm just gonna throw
this out real quick because you guys are
gonna be on break and you're have some
time to read and I really recommend that
you guys read this because although this
is not as sexy not that assault and rape
is sexy I just mean this is something I
think that's a little less clique baby
in terms of how our State Department is
essentially being depleted and what what
does this mean for the average person
like what country should we not visit in
case we get kidnapped there will not be
someone in an embassy so this is a great
time to be reading war on peace I'm
really guy I didn't expect you to bring
that up and it really means a lot to me
because I'm very proud of it and there
were brave whistleblowers who made this
possible - it's a great time for it
because everything in the news all the
impeachment stuff is partly a
consequence of the dismantling of our
diplomatic
apparatus and you see these great career
diplomats get up on the hill and talk
during the impeachment process about
trying to maintain professionalism in a
setting where actually there aren't even
diplomats on the calls anymore sometimes
there's a word diplomat I know every
guys are busy and you're you know you're
doing your laundry and you're driving
and you have kids you're doing lots of
things diplomat I mean these are people
that are around the world whose job it
is to just calm shit down
it it was important to me because we
don't have as much fiction about the
dramatic stories of diplomats as we do
about spies or sometimes it's easy to
sell explosions yes you actually explain
that the work of diplomacy to use the
word used earlier is actually sexy and
is important yeah and it's not
necessarily as flashy all the time but
these are the people who get you out of
a hostage situation if you're an
American abroad who can are the first
gatekeepers deciding who makes it into
our country who negotiate our way out of
conflict so that we don't have to have
our men and women die in those conflicts
and ability rooms have just been fired
those people have been fired on mass and
we have had a series of administration's
that have filled that void with a more
and more militarized posture around the
world and I was in Afghanistan and
Pakistan working for the state ban on
vacation in Kabul and I was actually
gooing Pakistan is also gorgeous
Pakistan is gorgeous Pakistan is very
green and mountainy and we're saying go
there we're saying there's no diplomats
and sadly partly as a result of a lot of
forces mucking up that region is not the
safest place to be but what I saw
firsthand and then what I extrapolate on
in this book is the stories of
incredibly brave diplomats at a time
when we are sidelining that profession
and all of our safety is threatened as a
result men are heroes - guys don't worry
we love you guys - men and women here is
all around this is what a good like a
stocking stuffer duo if you read both of
these books over the break you will be
the smartest person in the office and
you will kill every party you go to you
know bragging rights I have not seen
those two together I've been moving I've
been in a different city for tour every
day and I have the best cover art easily
of anybody don't you think god bless
wonderful artists who worked on both and
I am also a nightmare backseat driver in
every aspect of everything I do
creatively I joke about it on the
podcast and it got a big laugh from the
producers working on the podcast because
they know I'm a get into the editing I
could tell I can tell because I was
listening to one rest last night with
Rowena and Zelda right and there was a
you would come in with some of your
voice over and I could just it was so
tight it's I do a lot of mucking around
with scripts and mucking around in I
have nuts I don't get involved is she
get into the Pro Tools session that she
writes around different elements I
literally am like cut this point one
second delay there I don't like it I
come in I rerecord and similarly with
the art I was so good like I had a I had
a conversation with a director whose
work I really liked recently who was
saying like I'm working on the end
credits sequence for this
this superhero movie that I'm finishing
and like they brought me Helvetica like
anyone else would have been like you're
a fucking lunatic I was like I was I was
in this a wonderful artist did this Greg
Kulik did the hand and mouth mode motif
I wanted something the godfather like a
very simple image that distilled oh no
are very more very much in homage to
Saul Bass who did all this great
Hitchcock poster
yep and I was literally in Photoshop and
he put up with this god bless him like
cutting out with the the polygon lasso
the letters to get that Saul Bass jagged
that's almost like those serial killers
like the notes where they would cut down
there's a little bit the idea and then
look how I ruined his book pretty much
every page is dog-eared oh and you know
another little easter egg in this book
is the there's a lot of visual stuff
that goes into the print edition there
are illustrations which I'm just seeing
as you flip through that are done by my
sister and she's a character in the book
I love the little black cube and they're
black by the way I really I really oh
wait the oh she did the pen did the
internal yeah oh that's so cool they're
the section break illustration I wanted
to do a little like a Harry Potter thing
of interstitial visuals look at the
these are my notes I don't know if you
want them or if you need yeah for the
paperback do you have to have some notes
oh I did have I did have a question for
you okay how do you feel about the
algorithm in our news cycle I was just
in West Virginia and member Benton when
I said send me a picture of your
Huffington Post page remember that yes
and it was completely different
it was completely I was getting
different news in Westford a what was
your news and what was his news my
name's was all Donald Trump my view
because you love Donald Trump and mine
were about how mine were about Biden's
bad sort of hiss hiss turi like lead in
water it's very sophisticated something
about guns something I took a you're
like a hard policy news was it about
where I was because then I also just get
dog rescue videos okay let's do my
Huffington Post is dog rescue by the way
god bless
you for the dog rescue stuff okay I sit
I consume all of your content Whitney no
and I sit and I watch you save B's and
watch dogs and I'm like I'm just crying
looking at violet and yes violets in San
Diego was very happy and you know it's
something that we do obviously very
different things in your you know
changing the world on a global scale but
you know there is a have actually been a
little bit of a reckoning in animal
abuse as well like a little me too in
the animal world meow - as we call it
even though I'm not really cats I don't
know anything about cats I don't how to
rescue cats I don't know what they care
about but because it's abusing you know
women children anything vulnerable is
the same part of the brain as abusing
animals you know they say whenever
animal abuse is present another kind of
abuse is present you know not to be flip
about it but it is the classic serial
killer tell that's right that's right
action about super traitors but they say
when what a man is kicking the dog he's
just warming up you know and trafficking
exotic animals it's the same people that
traffic humans the traffic children it's
all it's a billion dollars so insane to
me it's so hard for me to understand the
psychology the state of mind you have to
be into it's a psychopath you to kick or
hit a dog it's a psychopath you know so
that's why I never have any compunction
I know you guys see me go after people
you know sometimes I can't control
myself on social media because it's the
same part of the brain so people that
want to delineate animal abuse and human
abuse like why would you care about
animals there's it's the same thing it's
all it's all the same and it's just the
animal abuse is more socially acceptable
so that's the ostensible abuse so my
thing is if that's going on in the front
lawn what's going on in the house with
those kids and you know for me you know
the way we treat animals is teaching
this next generation how to treat those
that are more powerless than them
humans you know it's really important
it's so that's why I think it's such a
big deal to me it teaches empathy to the
next generation when we take our kids to
zoos and we see you know the cuz all
they care about is animals they don't
really care about human beings and
they're really going oh this is how we
treat something that has less power
there was an incredibly upsetting story
in The Times Jeffrey Gettleman wrote at
really good reporting that required a
lot of going to dangerous places and
several different African countries
about primate trafficking
and it just if that story fucked me up
and nobody's I mean that's the thing
with with everything that's going on
with Michael Jackson no one has really
talked yet about all the animal abuse
the chubs and the bubbles and the chimps
that he had they were kept in cages so
that they didn't develop any muscle mass
to to train a chimp requires a
tremendous amount of abuse electrocution
drugging and this is another issue that
I have with morning shows and these new
shows is they have these animal trainers
on they have Cubs on think about what
has to happen to the mother of a lion
cub you know a lioness in order to get
its cub away well I know in the case of
this particular reporting about primates
that one of the tactics that gets used
because the parents become violent and
protective worse if you try to take away
is you know they just wind up killing
the parents and orphanage the the
children that they're taking yeah and no
and they'll killed their babies as well
you know elephants in captivity they
know that it's a dangerous situation so
oftentimes as soon as they have a baby
they'll try to kill it or they'll
succeed in killing it or their
reproductive system shuts down because
they know it's dangerous so when people
say breeding in captivity isn't that
would you know makes conservation not
true most the time it's really hard to
breed in captivity obviously there's a
complicated body of philosophy and law
around this and there are complicated
discussions to be had about where you
drop a line in terms of distinguishing
but happen of different species but I do
think fundamentally it flows from the
same problems we have as a species with
racism that we don't automatically see
like they're so genetically similar does
is it's so incumbent on us to treat I
mean the primate thing drives me crazy
the dolphin thing drives me crazy he's
these very sophisticated creatures that
we have very little insight into what's
going on with them psychologically but
we can tell they have incredibly complex
and sophisticated reactions to things we
do to them might happen
how freaking them so badly will have
billions and billions of dollars they
say that if an elephant is taken out of
an elephant is usually the you know the
biggest draw firs do if you take an
elephant out of a zoo it'll go bankrupt
almost immediately
these Barnum & Bailey they have billions
of dollars you know I know people who
they have terrorized they have paid
neighbors to stalk and
you know sanctuaries that are trying to
be set up I mean what goes on you know
for me like I mean I've had to move
because my life has been in danger from
these people or Psychopaths you know I
used to do coverage on my midday cable
news program I remember of like animal
rights issues and have sort of legal
analysts on and activists who are
arguing for sort of the the extreme set
that was arguing for like personhood
rights for you know various types of
animals and and there was a lot of logic
to that actually and I covered it in
part because I thought you know whether
you go that far or not it's worth
hearing that out and understanding the
place of compassion that it comes from
and and covering stories of animal abuse
is important yeah because it's just
teaching the next generation compassion
for those that are more voiceless than
them you know it's just kind of that
simple I assume your next book is going
to be about how NBC squashed other
important content such as 1600 Penn and
that is a deep cut we that's funny we've
all been canceled
NBC has there is obviously a conspiracy
that 6,300 Penn and Whitney are still on
NBC so I love you I have to get you out
of here I'm sure thank you for taking
the time this is a blast I get the
podcast right now get the books right
now these books will get you laid
consensually
[Music]